california is taking steps to help send
students back to the classroom for
in-person learning
governor gavin newsom says 10 percent of
the state's vaccine supply will be
reserved for educators
and school staff starting next month so
far close to 42 million people in the
u.s have received at least
one coveted 19 vaccine dose the new
daily case count is down
64 percent from the all-time high
setback on january 2nd
this is an average of 1800 people still
died from the coronavirus each day this
week
michael george is here with the latest
michael good morning jeff good morning
nearly
60 million doses of the vaccine have
been administered that's more than 12
percent of the american population
that's received at least one dose
but just as the pace was picking up
vaccine distribution hit a snag this
week
severe storms disrupted shipments
causing the closing of some vaccination
centers
and the cancellation of tens of
thousands of appointments
car a boston dentist is one of many
whose scheduled second dose appointment
got canceled annoyed is probably a good
word
confused that's the kind of what next
steps to take in los
angeles more than 12 thousand
appointments were cancelled
a situation repeated in too many places
sideswiped by the storms that
crisscrossed the country this week
6 million doses due to the weather all
50 states have been impacted
three days of shipments got delayed by
snowden delivery workers
road closures and power outages at more
than 2
000 vaccine sites that left all of this
week's shipments to new york delayed
arizona officials may push back the
opening of the next phase of vaccines
the weather delays may actually play a
role we had been
estimating moving into phase
1b on a statewide basis keeping in mind
some counties
may not be ready to do that
beginning mid to march and still there's
reluctance among many to get vaccinated
a third of the population polled say
that and the military is no exception
it is completely voluntary two-thirds
overall don't accept the vaccine
and less than half in the elite 82nd
airborne division
despite a push from defense secretary
lloyd austin in a day one vow to troops
to do everything we can to vaccinate our
workforce
you've stolen a vaccine from somebody
that needs it more than you
but then there are those who cut in line
to get vaccinated
two florida women were caught on police
cameras posing
as seniors they weren't and now face
charges
and while that case highlights some
problems with the system it also shows
how many people are eager to get the
vaccine
in fact where to get the cova vaccine is
the most google term in america over the
last month
dana all right michael thank you